welcome back to new rock stars I'm Eric
Voss and this is a breakdown of the
ending and post-credit scene of the
Marvels spoiler warning before I
continue because this movie's final
minutes include some exceptionally huge
tie-ins to the MCU and to the Multiverse
at large that directly set up Deadpool 3
and Secret Wars grab one of these Flur
and inspired shirts at nerd riot. shop
to support what we're doing here and
chat with us about all this stuff in
person at our live show in Los Angeles
on Thursday November 16th at brain dead
Studios ticket infot in the description
okay our spoiler delay is passed holy
crap this movie ended with Kamala Khan
pulling a Nick Fury and recruiting a new
team of Young Avengers starting with
Kate bishop and one mid-credit scene
with Monica Rambo stuck in an X-Men
Universe with her mother Maria as binary
and Kelsey gramar returning as Hank
McCoy beast from the fox X-Men films in
the X mansion so much to discuss here
okay so in the Marvel's film Captain
Marvel Carol Danvers Monica Rambo and
Kamala Khan all become cosmically
entangled due to the three of them all
sharing some light based Powers meaning
all three of them them got their powers
from the same source of cosmic radiation
this entanglement begins after the Creed
General darbin discovered the other
Bengal on the planetoid M b418 and used
it to tear holes in the jump Point
teleportation Network that's the
hexagonal grid previously known in the
MCU as the unn we learn in this movie
that the Bengals are the quantum bands
that were used to create these various
jump points to travel across the Galaxy
but by creating two many jump points is
kind of like fracking and it causes the
Shale of the universe to loosen and
create these fissures in reality darb
Ben's goal we learn is to save the cre
home world of Hala which has had its
resources depleted from a civil war
following the actions of Carol Danver
whom they nicknamed the annihilator
after she destroyed the cre Supreme
intelligence the son of Hal's solar
system is dying and now darbin is using
her Quantum band to open portals in the
squirrel colony of tarx to siphon their
air to the planet aladana to take their
water and to Earth to take the power of
our son Valkyrie cameos to take the
surviving Scrolls led by Emperor Dro to
a new home presumably new Asgard on
Earth which I assume is now a kind of
protectorate following the American
president's War Declaration on all
extraterrestrials on Earth and secret
invasion they used Carol's scroll memory
technology to scan their memories for
darvin's weaknesses and we learned via
flashback that Carol actually visited
Maria Rambo after the cancer returned
sometime during the blip while Monaco is
gone and that Maria never let go of hope
that Monaco would return meanwhile the
con family hangs out with Nick Fury on
the saber space station while Flur and
egg sacks appear all over the station
Darin's latest tears in reality ruptur
the saber station elevators so Nick Fury
and the others have to use the flurin to
swallow all the saber Cadets so that
carried in those pocket Dimensions all
of them can be transferred safely back
to Earth this is hilariously said to
Barbara strand's rendition of memory
from cats Carol Monica and Kamala
confront darb Ben 3on one darbin gets
both Quantum bands and creates a fissure
in reality so large that these hexagonal
tiles split off and crack widens and
widens opening to another universe
darbin is destroyed in the energy surge
and Monica realizes that they need one
of them to stitch that c crack back
together from the other side Carol and
Cala Empower Monica so that she becomes
her Photon form and she repairs that
crack but seals herself on the other
side of it the film ends at the Rambo
home in Louisiana Carol and Camala climb
into the family's plane and Carol says
that she's just holding on to it until
Monica gets back echoing that hope that
Maria had that Monica would come back
from the blip someday Cala says that
they work so good together which gets
her thinking and then we lead to this
film's final scene in New York City Kate
Bishop appears tossing a slice of pizza
to her golden retriever lucky so Haley
St Feld who also boy squin Stacy in the
animated spiderverse films played
Hawkeye Clint Barton Protege Kate Bishop
in the Hawkeye series and lucky the
pizza dog loves pizza she wears her
purple jacket that she ended that series
with to her left are dozens more arrows
presumably the same mix of explosive and
pimp Tech resizing ones that we saw
Clint use on that series sitting in the
shadows is Kamala Khan behind her is one
of Kate's archery targets and to her
left Kate's various trophies from
archery fencing gymnastics martial arts
and yeah probably also a trophy for The
Uncanny ability to immediately flip a
quarter like a bu Camala wearing a black
ball cap which might be a not to Kevin
feige she says Kate Bishop did you think
you were the only superhero in the world
Kate smiles and says I'm 23 and Camala
says oh I know I've been reading up on
you and she holds up the glass tablet
that Monica had used earlier in the film
to bring up information on her saber
must be sharing Resources with the dodc
and other government agencies on
superhumans and various Vigilantes by
the way we learned saber stands for
strategic Aerospace biophysics and exol
linguistic response Kate asks where did
you get that and Kamala says I found it
under my couch and I love this because
earlier Cala was sweeping up that mess
and she probably swept this awesome
tablet under her couch to grab later and
just played it cool Kamala says you just
became part of a larger universe which
at the moment is just me mostly I do
have feelers out though did you know
Ant-Man had a daughter Kate asks what do
you want and Cala says I'm putting
together a team and I want you on it and
then after a pause she follows up with
please and Kate kind of Just Smiles and
tilts her head so obviously Cala is
recreating the iconic very first MCU
post credit scene in the 2008 Iron Man
film in which Nick Fury appeared in the
Shadows of Tony Stark's Mansion to
recruit him to join the Avenger
initiative and says pretty much the same
words you think you're the only
superhero in the world Mr Stark you
become part of a bigger Universe you
just don't know it yet so did Nick Fury
tell Calo what he had told Tony Stark
probably not because Nick Fury is all
about you know everything being
classified did the story get shared by
Scott Lang in the this powered Life
podcast that Cala used to learn what
happened in the Battle of Earth in
endgame I'm just thinking maybe a
transcript or audio recording of that
conversation was story on the tablet
Camala alludes to Scott Lang's daughter
Cassie Lang played by Katherine Newton
and itman the was Quanto Mania but
Camala should know that Scott has a
daughter because he brings up Cassie
Lang in his book look out for the little
guy which you know Kamala would have
read every page of so yes Kamala is
putting together a Young Avengers lineup
that will include herself and Kate
bishop and Cassie Lang other possible
candidates could include Peter Parker as
well as Wanda's son Billy maximoff AKA
Wiccan who is believed to be played by
Joe lock in the upcoming series Agatha
darkhole Diaries the lineup could also
include Hulk's son scar who was
introduced at the end of She-Hulk as
well as America Chavez and rivy Williams
ironheart The Young Avengers usually
includes Patriot Eli Bradley who was
played by Elijah Richardson in the
Falcon of the Winter Soldier there's
also generally a Nate Richards AKA iron
lad a variant of Kang the Conqueror and
nazari Thompson played a young Victor
timely in Loki season 2 episode 3 one
idea that we've discussed before is that
while the adult Avengers are all off
world dealing with the multiversal
crisis in battle world and Avengers
Secret Wars some of these youths could
hold things down on Earth and if that
ends up being the case I don't think
Peter Parker would be part of the Young
Avengers lineup and this could just be a
film or like a Disney plus series or
some kind of event that features
everybody else thank you to better help
for sponsoring this video if you're
spending hours at the gym trying to get
your body ready for the stress of the
holidays you might want to think about
putting the same work into getting your
mind ready for the stress of the
holidays and to do that you'll want to
get help from a licensed therapist with
better help starting therapy can be hard
the right therapist for you might not be
in your area and some people struggle
with the face to-face interaction of
therapy with better help you can have
your therapy sessions as a phone call as
a video chat or even via messaging if
you prefer that whatever is the most
comfortable version of therapy for you
just click the link in the description
and answer a few questions about what
you're looking for from therapy and what
your preferences are better help will
then match you with the therapist from
their Network that's right for you and
if you don't really fit with that
therapist which is a common thing with
therapy you can easily switch to a new
therapist for no additional cost without
stressing about insurance who's in your
network or anything like that mental
health is quite the journey but it is an
important one to start your journey
towards better mental health click the
link in the description or visit
betterhelp.com neww rockstars to help
support this Channel and get you 10% off
your first month with better help okay
onto the mid credit scene Monica wakes
up in hospital bed with her mother Maria
beside her wrapped in a blanket
conveniently covering what she's wearing
this is a reversal of Monica UND dusting
from the blip beside her mother's empty
hospital bed Monica says mom Mom Mom and
Maria just stares at her confused saying
mom and Monica says I missed you so much
Maria says missed me and Monica just
breaks down saying I'm so sorry and a
door slides open and we hear a familiar
voice asking how's our mysterious
visitor and Maria says she seems a
little disoriented and Monica asks where
are we what happened and we see it is Dr
Hank McCoy AKA Beast played by Kelsey
gramar so we last Saw gramar play the
character in 2014's X-Men Days of Future
Past part of the fox X-Men continuity
that movie ended in a restored timeline
after Wolverine altered history back in
1973 to prevent the development of
Sentinel Technology based on mystique's
DNA erasing that post-apocalyptic future
while also retconning the events of
2006's X-Men the Last Stand that was the
first movie in which gramer played McCoy
so Wolverine's walking around the X
Manion in kind of this like happy-ending
epilogue and he passes Kelsey gramer
who's like oh we see that Scott Summers
is alive again Jean Gray is alive again
they're all teaching at Charles Xavier
School alongside storm and Charles it's
like the year 2023 or 2024 everything's
great but here in this scene Kelsey
gramer is not wearing the prosthetic
makeup they created a VFX likeness of
him using the same type of process that
they use for Hulk Thanos and She-Hulk as
a result notice how McCoy's head is a
more normal proportion to the rest of
his body he has more pronounced
underbite fangs and his hair and beard
have a more aesthetic sweep to them in
line with the comics and the '90s
animated take on the character but he is
a CGI character with that same kind of
tiny nose and cheekbones looking a lot
like ruffalo's character model for Hulk
just blue like when we hear grammer's
voice I will admit it doesn't quite
sound like it is coming from this figure
on screen but when Monica asks what
happened McCoy says we were hoping you
could tell us all we know is that binary
found you my theory you somehow crossed
through a tear in SpaceTime you are now
in a reality parallel to your own which
is of course impossible Maria AKA binary
stands her blanket falling off revealing
her fit and passing a screen beside
Monica that has an X symbol in the
corner and binary asks you think there
might be confusion happening and McCoy
responds confusion is but the first step
on the journey to knowledge and binary's
like uh okay and then she says I'll take
it from here and McCoy says Charles ask
for an update and then he leaves saying
I'll come back and check on you later
and somehow avoids veering into sicho
Bob to say oh Maria you don't become a
mutant scientist without learning a
thing or two about the multiv BOS and in
this wi shot we see the classic X doors
on the basement level of Charles
Xavier's mansion and McCoy is wearing a
white lab coat over no shirt but pants
colored dark blue and a yellow border
cut off at the calf yes this is a
universe where X-Men dress like X-Men
binary meanwhile wears a white and red
suit with two AU colored stars on the
chest and we push it on binary as she
asks Monica who are you and Monica just
Sayes oh so if you were listening
closely during this scene you can
actually hear two different X-Men film
scores John OT man's X2 X-Men United
theme and John otman Days of Future Past
score so you hear the dark
biring that's from X-Men Days of Future
Past but also
the that's from the X2 theme this is the
latest in Marvel Studios puling Classic
X-Men riffs like hearing Ron Wan's
animated X-Men demon Multiverse of
Madness and the music sting that
accompanied the reveal that Kamala Khan
is a
mutant so Monaco Rambo has crossed
through the Multiverse into an X-Men
Universe now we know this is not the 838
Universe from Doctor Strange in the
Multiverse of Madness that had a Patrick
Stewart Charles Xavier in it because
Maria is alive here and she's binary
instead of Captain Marvel a member of
the Illuminati and McCoy refers to
Charles Xavier who is still alive in
this reality but remember in Multiverse
of Madness that a38 Universe Charles
referenced a line from 2014 means X-Men
Days of Future Past just because someone
stumbles loses their way it doesn't mean
they're lost forever just because
someone stumbles and loses their way
doesn't mean they're lost forever so I
think this right here is a future
version of that restored timeline as it
was left at the end of X-Men Days of
Future Past as a time travel plot that
dealt with Logan's Consciousness
slipping back into the body of his
younger self Days of Future Past did a
great job reconciling the complicated
eras of the franchise and I truly
believe Kevin feige is treating those
events as a Nexus moment from which the
X-Men universe that he's going to cross
over with Will Branch from it's really
the most logical move because X-Men Days
of the Future Past in my opinion was the
last good X-Men movie and I'm leaving
out Deadpool and Logan from that I'm
saying the last good movie that had
X-Men in the title like after X-Men Days
of Future Past X-Men films proceeded on
kind of a new timeline with a younger
cast 2016's X-Men apocalypse and 2019s
dark Phoenix during this time we also
got 2016's Deadpool and 2018s Deadpool 2
which took place in their own meta
corner of the X-Men continuity and
2017's Logan which took place in the
future year of 2029 after most mutants
had died out now some believe that movie
takes place in the same continuity of
the Days of Future Past happy ending
that was in 2023 or 2024 so like 5 years
after that but the Logan film implied
that it had been decades since young
mutants had been springing up naturally
and in Days of Future Past that was
again 2023 or 2024 Charles X Xavier
school was thriving so for it to go from
that to Logan in 5 years would just be
kind of a steep shift Shan Ley and Ryan
Reynolds have said that when it comes to
Deadpool 3 they are not going to touch
Wolverine's death in the Logan film they
consider that to be sacred so I think
Logan's just going to be part of its own
timeline in the Multiverse and I think
for the X-Men universe that the 616
universe will cross over with the X-Men
characters in Deadpool 3 and in secret
Wars fige is going to continue building
this Days of Future Past happy ending
epilog mostly because everyone was there
and it's the most opportune sandbox of
characters from that o era from which to
pull memberberry cameos like this the
fact that it's Kelsey Grammar and not
Nicholas Holt tells us that it is the
older era not the new younger cast
besides Holt seems to be committed to DC
to play like Lex Luther and Superman
Legacy we think now why beast and not
like Charles Xavier storm Cyclops Jean
Gray or like Wolverine well for the
context of the scene they needed a
scientist who would be immediately
recognizable as a mutant from the fox
X-Men era like their universes Bruce
Banner or Tony Stark or Steven strange
or Wong and they already featured
Patrick Stewart and Multiverse of
Madness so McCoy is the play but this
universe doesn't just have X-Men in it
but other Marvel heroes so who is binary
binary is actually a recent addition to
Marvel Comics introduced in December
2021 she's a duplicate of Carol danverse
who gets trapped in a faraday cage and
gets formed when Carol's Photon blasts
are shaped into a humanlike form who is
assimilated parts of Carol's memories
but cannot communicate verbally so this
version of binary played by lesana Lynch
seems to be the Captain Marvel of this
reality in which Maria Rambo got hit
with a cosmic radiation instead remember
in the flashback of this movie Carol
even tells Maria that it should have
been her I think the idea is in every
other reality Maria Rambo not Carol
daners becomes the cosmically irradiated
hero and note that in this reality Maria
did not have children Monica Rambo was
never born Kevin feige was recently
quoted in the Marvel official timeline
book an introduction in which he said on
the Multiverse note we recognize that
there are stories movies and series that
are canonical to Marvel but were created
by different storytellers during
different periods of Marvel's history
the timeline presented in this book is
specific to the mcu's sacred timeline
through phase 4 but as we move forward
and dive deeper into the Multiverse Saga
you never know when timelines May crash
or converge hint hint spoiler alert
Marvel Studios has already broken that
ice with Toby Maguire and Andrew
Garfield and Spider-Man no way home and
Doctor Strange is spell that opened a
purple Rift to the Multiverse of the
Sony Marvel characters is the same kind
of thing as Darin's Rift opening up to
the fox X-Men continuity following Days
of Future Past so as we look ahead to
Deadpool 3 Monica Rambo is trapped in a
reality with that original lineup of
liveaction X-Men that feige began his
career as an associate producer advising
the look in the tone of while the
director Brian Singer ban Marvel comics
from the Set Young Kevin feige opened up
his office to Hugh Jackman to come read
X-Men comics and learn what wolverine is
all about Sean Levy recently told Jake's
takes what Jackman's reaction was to
them bringing back the classic suit
colors when we first told Kevin feige
that Hugh Jackman wanted to join the
movie my recollection is damn near the
first thing he said was okay but let's
go with the blue and yellow just tell me
we're going with the blue and yellow and
then when I approach Hugh at that idea
he's like fu yeah now you have to bleep
me but you get it he was like hell yes
so for Avengers Secret Wars expect a
brawl among classic MCU Avengers and fox
era X-Men actors that are wearing more
vibrant suits I recently made the case
in a different video that 2014's dates
of future past 2016's Deadpool and
2017's Logan are better than most MCU
films not all MCU films but most which p
a lot of you off I'm not surprised look
I think the bad X-Men movies are much
worse than the bad MCU movies but I'm
just saying this that Marvel Studios
isn't the only franchise that has made
good Marvel movies I just think we need
to rewatch all of the X-Men films which
is something this channel will be doing
in 2024 so our Easter egg breakdown of
the Marvel's film is coming to this
channel on Saturday it's going to be
hosted by myself and Jessica Clemens
it's going to be a lot of fun subscribe
to all three channels in the new
rockstars Network follow me on Instagram
and Twitter at eaos thanks for watching
and I'll see you next time
bye
[Music]
a